Okay, so welcome to video number 28. We
are going to look at now as part of the
trade idea generation
process, we're going to look at data
mining and processing mistakes and
solutions. So far,
we have gone through the quantitative
process and we've looked at long ideas and
short ideas and also
turnarounds, X growth names and value
traps. What we've done is we've gone
through forward-looking
metrics, our identification process, and
we've gone through an evidence process
looking at
backwards-looking quantitative data as
well. What we're going to be looking at
here in this video
is data mining and processing mistakes and
some solutions for the forward-looking
quantitative
identification process. What we're trying
to achieve here is that we want to get our
quantitative
spreadsheet work to reflect the reality of
a sector as closely as possible.
How can we even make sensible conclusions
to determine whether there's genuine
positive
and negative outliers in a sector and
analyze everything else in between
if we don't know for certain that the data
that we've downloaded, the sector data
that we're looking
at, accurately reflects reality? Now,
what's interesting is that ITPM teaching
methods went globally public in 2013.
And over a number of years, we witnessed
and noticed some patterns that emerged,
patterns of behavior
that emerged amongst retail traders at
ITPM when they were doing their
quantitative processing.
Most commonly, what we saw were patterns
where people were making some
some basic errors in their quantitative
processing identification phase.
So, what we're going to do here is feed
back this information to you.
So, you just simply don't make these
mistakes and you erase them immediately.
So, you save yourself a ton of time in the
identification phase of the quantitative
processing.
So, it's really important that when you
start this, that you get off on the right
foot and you eliminate
all of the common errors that we've
witnessed, that we've seen over the last
decade.
And what it really comes down to is a lack
of attention to detail and just some
really basic common sense.
And, unfortunately, trading is not an easy
pursuit.
It does require a lot of attention to
detail and common sense.
But, from a teaching perspective, from an
ITPM perspective, we have to be very, very
careful here.
Because, there is always a catch-22 when
teaching people from scratch how to trade.
Because, if you want to become, or anybody
wants to become, a successful trader over
their lifetime or career,
you have to become self-sustainable.
You have to be able to only rely on
yourself.
In addition, you have to have a very
strong work ethic and you have to have the
ability to be able to work smart and not
hard.
So, not going down endless rabbit holes to
get to information that's irrelevant.
Working smart is important.
So, if you recall, the four principles of
ITPM, self-sustainability, work ethic,
free information, and working smart, not
hard.
There's very good reasons why we have
these principles.
It's because we've been in this game for a
very long time.
And, we know what traits are required to
produce consistently profitable traders.
And, part of self-sustainability, work
ethic, and the ability to work smart, not
hard,
is the ability to be able to process and
understand large amounts of data.
And, guess what?
That requires a lot of attention to
detail.
On top of that, you have to have the
ability to interpret the data.
And, that requires common sense.
And, the only way that you're going to
acquire this skill set, or these skill
sets,
and be good at implementing these
principles over your career, over your
lifetime, is if you do the work yourself.
And, find the answers yourself.
Good traders find the answers themselves.
So, the catch-22 here, from a teaching
perspective, is that we want to give you
all the information
that enables you to be successful in
trading.
But, we know at the same time, that to be
successful in trading, you have to do it
yourself.
So, I guess the best analogy I can give
here, is that we can provide you the
golden keys,
to the golden door that opens to the
golden kingdom.
But, you have to open the door yourself
and walk over the threshold.
So, from a teaching perspective, we have
to draw a line in the sand that we simply
do not cross.
Because, if we did the opposite, and we
told you all the time exactly what to do,
and what to buy,
what to sell, when to buy it, when to sell
it, etc., etc., you simply would never
become a good trader.
You wouldn't be self sustainable, you
wouldn't be self sustainable, you wouldn't
have a solid work ethic,
you wouldn't have the ability to work
smart and not hard, and you wouldn't have
attention to detail and common sense.
We would just be doing you a massive
disservice.
So, when it comes to data processing
mistakes, we're going to point you in the
right direction.
But, of course, you have to then go off
and do all of the work yourself to
generate your own trade ideas.
So, the first step is to eliminate all of
the common mistakes that people make in
the beginning,
when they have very little attention to
detail and common sense.
Now, the good news is, is that the more
you practice processing and analyzing big
data sets and interpreting them,
the more attention to detail and common
sense you're going to get.
And this will actually help you outside of
trading as well, just in the general
world, in everyday life.
You will become, generally, just a lot
sharper, and you'll be able to spot
discrepancies and potential opportunities,
not just in trading, but even outside
trading as well.
You will just become better at self
sustainability, your work ethic, working
smart, not hard,
and have much better attention to detail
and common sense the more you engage in
the systematic
trade idea generation process and the
quantitative process at the identification
stage.
So, when you're going through your monthly
processes, you're going to be downloading
data.
Now, this data, ITPM, does provide you
with updates of the US Stock Screener
sheet that we've looked
at previously in the PTM video series that
is downloaded from Zaxx.
It's available on a monthly basis in the
ITPM data section on the website.
And this data is a NAICS classification
data that's updated every month.
And it is available publicly.
You can download it yourself.
It's accessible and downloadable by
everybody.
However, you do need to learn how to
organize the data and process it correctly
with attention to detail and common sense.
Additionally, data sources can, of course,
change over time and in the future.
You have to learn how to search for data
sets using search engines like Google
and not just rely on people to tell you
where to find it and do all of the work
for you.
So, by now, you should know that this is
not how the Institute of Trading and
Portfolio Management works.
You will never be a consistently
profitable trader if you constantly rely
on people
to tell you what to do, where to get
information that's important,
and then they literally do the work for
you.
It's impossible for you to become a
consistently profitable trader if that's
the route you take.
So, you have to learn to look for this
data yourself and rely on yourself and
also learn how to process it correctly.
So, you can process correctly by yourself
with no help from anybody on a regular
monthly basis.
Now, here's our first problem with big
data sets and downloading big data sets
from third-party sources.
It's trusting that all the numbers are
correct and accurate.
So, when visiting websites like Zaxx or
Nasdaq.com and downloading the
forward-looking data
for around 2200-plus stocks, there's a
major problem with doing so.
You're engaging in an exercise of a
large-scale data dump and you will be
downloading data
with differing labels from the ones you
are used to in the PTM video series.
There will be different titles for the
columns in the spreadsheet when you
download it
and you have to organize the data into a
recognizable and easy-to-use format
similar to the way we have done it or
exactly the same as the way we have done
it with our 11 numbers.
So, we have stock price, market
capitalization, earnings per share zero,
which is last year's
reported EPS, EPS1, which is
forward-looking EPS of the current year,
EPS2, forward-looking EPS of next year,
earnings growth 1, earnings growth 1,
earnings growth 2, PE1, PE2, PEG1, and
PEG2.
These are the standard 11 numbers that we
want to get in any download to reflect
reality for each individual stock in a
sector,
and of course, therefore, the sector as a
whole. And when you initially download
spreadsheets like the ones
from Zaxx or Nasdaq.com, these titles will
not be there. You have to rearrange it and
organize the sheet to get it all accurate
and correct.
So, that's the first step, but this
creates also a bigger problem in terms of
the big data dump.
Large data dumps, when we are downloading
them, if we're not doing any work
whatsoever on the numbers,
we are making the assumption that every
number in all rows, columns, and cells for
2200-plus stocks
is 100% accurate. As traders, we have to
have attention to detail and common sense,
and we have to be as
accurate as possible in reflecting
reality. One of the biggest issues we
always see at ITPM
is retail traders just simply being too
trusting with the numbers and not checking
or eyeballing the numbers
and fixing the errors to ensure an
accurate reflection of reality. And that
is attention to detail.
On top of that, having common sense to
enable sensible conclusions about the
sector.
What's happening here, if you download a
big data spreadsheet from a third-party
source,
if you're doing absolutely nothing to
cleanse the data, what you're doing is, is
you're trusting
a paste-special data dump from a
third-party source and you're trusting
that the numbers are 100% accurate.
By not checking and fixing any issues with
the data, the numbers that you're basing
your decisions on
to identify both positive and negative
outliers, and of course, everything in
between,
could just be totally incorrect. So your
conclusions will just be meaningless and
wrong.
So how can we even begin to consider
taking real money positions with real
money in a trading account
account if we don't even know if our
ideas, our trade ideas, reflect reality?
We have to get the data of a chosen sector
to reflect reality as closely as possible.
And we have to have total confidence in
the data and our findings.
Now, the good news is, out of our 11
numbers that we organize our spreadsheets
into as part of the
identification process, as long as you can
get the stock price and the EPS numbers or
estimates accurate,
all the other data can just be worked out
using Excel formulas.
So when we're working out, for example,
PE, it's just the stock price over the
EPS.
So if you get the stock price right and
you get the EPS estimates right, you're
going to get PE correct.
The earnings growth numbers, they are just
percentage differences from one EPS number
to another EPS number.
If you get the percentages right, you're
going to get earnings growth percentage
right.
For PEG ratio, it's just PE divided by the
earnings growth percentage.
So if you get the stock price right and
the EPS right, and you've calculated PE
and the earnings growth
number correctly, you're going to get the
PEG number right.
So everything goes back to just getting
the stock price and the EPS estimates
accurate.
So something that you're going to find
that happens when you download
spreadsheets from third-party data
sources,
and in particular with the Zacks or
Nasdaq.com download, you're going to find
that the cells in the spreadsheet are not
live.
So we have a solution for that. It's very
straightforward. We make the cells live
and we eliminate any rogue cells.
So please, when you download a spreadsheet
from a third-party data source, just
eyeball the goddamn numbers.
Don't blindly go through a spreadsheet and
not eyeball it and see on a basic cursory
eyeballing if the numbers look right.
So eyeball the numbers and just see if
they make sense. Have attention to detail,
please.
When you just do a cursory, non-thorough
eyeballing, so without really going into
great detail,
you may find that some of the numbers
don't make sense.
Most of the time, this is because you've
downloaded a spreadsheet from a
third-party data source that is big data
and the cells are not live.
We have to make them live and make the
numbers as accurate as possible.
So if we look at this sector here, for
example, in the first step, when we've
downloaded the spreadsheet,
we've downloaded the data and we're
drilling down into a particular sector.
So for example, like this sector, apparel
manufacturing, the first thing we would do
is just eyeball the sector.
And because we've got a decent level of
attention to detail, we're going to find
potentially rogue cells.
And here in this sector, just by
eyeballing the data, we can see that
something is wrong with EPS1 or EG1 for
Capri Holdings.
So we can see that last year's EPS of
$3.89, it's in the spreadsheet as falling
to $1.50.
But the earnings growth is negative
27.89%.
But how can it be? EPS dropping from $3.89
to $1.50 is not losing 27.89% of your
earnings.
It's not negative 27.89%. It's actually
negative 61.43%.
So in this situation, and this can happen
and be very common.
It can happen a lot because we're dealing
with 2200 plus stocks
in a big data download from a third-party
source that doesn't have live cells.
In this particular situation, either the
EPS estimate is wrong or the paste special
of whoever has put this spreadsheet
together has failed and has corrupted the
EG1 cell.
So how do we actually go about fixing
this? Well, it's very easy and
straightforward.
Remember, as long as you can get the stock
price and EPS numbers accurate,
all other data can be worked out just
using Excel formulas.
So we make the cells live. So we go off
and we just do a very quick and simple
investigation.
We check the EPS estimates from publicly
available sources and add in the stock
price to the spreadsheet
in order to make all of our cells live.
And here for this example, we've just used
Yahoo Finance. There will of course be
always multiple
other free sources. Just start Googling
and stop crying. Do the work.
Now here we realize the problem in the
spreadsheet because we have $3.89 in Yahoo
Finance for last year's EPS.
We realize the problem in the spreadsheet
must be with the earnings growth number
being corrupted in some way.
So according to Yahoo Finance, we have
$3.89 for EPS a year ago, and we have an
average consensus estimate
from analysts for the current year of
$1.50. So we know our estimates in the
spreadsheet for earnings per share
are actually correct. So whoever's put
this spreadsheet together on the other
side at our third party
that we're downloading the data from, they
have got the EPS estimates correct in the
spreadsheet,
but the percentage number for EG1 is off.
So what do we do about it? Do we cry about
it? Do we send emails to
ITPM asking if there's any other data
sources? Do we go down to the local bar
and start asking our friends
how to find data online? Do we go on
internet forums, create threads, hoping
and praying that somebody is
going to come to our rescue to help us
organize our data properly? Do we post
things on social media about
ITPM being an education company that
doesn't provide you with shortcuts to
become multimillionaires or do we just
give up?
Well, of course not. We just do the work.
So we add in the stock price data for
Capri Holdings
and we make all the sales live and then we
repeat it for every stock in the sector.
So you can see here in the
first screenshot at the top of the screen,
we've got the percentage calculation
formula for EG1 and we make that
sell live negative 61.5%. This is possible
because we have the stock price and we
have the right EPS data.
Then we move on to the other cells for
Capri Holdings.
We work out the PE ratios. That's the next
screenshot below in the middle.
We work out the PE ratios for period one
and period two.
And then in the bottom screenshot, we work
out the PEG ratios for period one and
period two.
That's for Capri Holdings. And then we do
it for the rest of the sector as well.
And of course, in Excel, there are
shortcuts
to working out numbers quickly, but we
want to make sure that we have attention
to detail
to make sure that if we use shortcuts, the
numbers are still coming out accurately.
So all cells for Capri Holdings are then
made live and then you can auto fill down.
But where there are negative or positive
minorities, you're going to have to
overwrite the formulas.
We will come on to this processing mistake
in a moment. But what you've just seen
here,
every time you're going through the
process of generating a trade idea, you're
going to have to do this.
You're going to have to make live cells
and eliminate rogue cells. It's the first
step to making sure
that your sector reflects reality as
closely as possible and all your cells are
actually correct
and accurate. Now, there is a mistake that
some people make at this stage.
They think that they have to do this for
all 2200 plus stocks every month, all the
time. You don't.
Don't try to make the numbers of the 2200
plus stocks live in the spreadsheet and
check all of them.
It's way too much work. This is not
working smart. This is working too hard.
You're going down
huge, endless rabbit holes. So do it when
you have drilled down to less than 20 or
so stocks.
Use your time wisely and work smart, not
hard. Now, something else that falls under
attention to detail
is company's financial year ends. You have
to make sure that the data lines up
is a particular company's financial year
end. So in this sector of nine stocks, for
example,
two of them have their financial year end
in March and another two of them have
their financial year
end at the end of January. Now, this is
just down to having a bit of attention to
detail and common
sense, thinking about what you're looking
at on the screen. What sector are you
looking at?
Does it have seasonal factors? Well,
financial year ends change or can be
different across stocks
in seasonal sectors. It happens a lot. So
this is the apparel manufacturing sector
and some companies choose to have their
financial year end at certain times. So
like the end of March
and the end of January because they make
the bulk of their earnings during the
holiday season and
in the January after holiday season sales.
So whilst you're processing and checking
forward EPS estimates,
you need to make sure that the right years
line up across the sector. In a big data
dump,
sometimes the numbers will be off. So
whoever's on the other side at the third
party data source,
they may have put the wrong EPS for the
wrong financial year in a cell. So for
example, the EPS
number from two years ago might be last
year's number and last year's number might
be this year's number.
You have to double check it and get it
right. Be accurate with your financial
year ends and get it
correct. Now, one of the biggest errors we
see is actually using common sense to
understand positive
and negative EPS. So changes when
companies go from positive to negative EPS
and changes when companies
go from negative to positive EPS. So this
creates a problem in big data dumps
because whoever's on the other
side has done paste special across 2200
plus stocks and the data can end up being
spurious and not make common sense.
So in our example, you will notice from
the initial data download that PVH Corp
and Under Armour have
negative, so loss making EPS for last year
in year zero and they have positive EPS in
year one.
So they're going from losses to profits
from year zero last year to the current
year, year one. So when
calculating the earnings growth
percentage, the big data download has
simply done an autofill and the
numbers are very large and the
calculations are just wrong. So think of
it the other way around in terms of
a positive EPS, if a stock goes from $1 of
earnings to $3 of losses,
how much of the earnings of the company
have they lost in percentage terms?
Well, if you did the calculation here in
absolute terms, then they'd be losing $4
in total from an initial position
of $1. So they'd be losing 400% of their
earnings. But how can a company lose 400%
of their earnings?
They can't. A company can only lose 100%
of their earnings. On the flip side, if
we're going from a
a loss making operation to a profit making
position, you can't recover 400% of your
losses, you can
only recover 100% of your losses. You need
to overwrite these cells with the number
100 for 100%, so loss making to profit in
this case, plus positive 100%.
And for operations that are going from a
profit making position to losses, you have
to overwrite the cell with negative 100%,
minus 100%.
So when you're going through your
quantitative processing for a sector and
you're cleaning up all the data, making
the cells live, you have to watch out for
this situation.
You have to overwrite the cells manually
that previously had a formula in and
overwrite them for either positive 100% or
negative 100%.
Now something else that creates a problem
when it comes to attention to detail and
common sense in the quantitative process
is the law of small numbers.
So when you download big data dumps that
work out earnings growth percentages that
are based on EPS, you're going to find
quite often very wild earnings growth
percentage numbers.
So numbers like 500%, 1000%, 5000%, etc.
And this can just be because a company is
going from a very small EPS number to
another number that's just large.
So for example, if a company last year had
one cent of earnings, but this year has 10
cents of earnings.
They're going to be in the downloaded
spreadsheet calculated on an auto fill
with a paste special as having 900%
earnings growth.
Now, if we're using some common sense
here, does this mean that we should
automatically deduce that this company is
the positive outlier in the sector?
Of course not.
We've got to use common sense here.
Look at the company's EPS in more detail.
So for example, like the last two, three
or five years, the company may even be a
revenue growth story, or they may have
actually made 12 cents in EPS two years
ago.
Meaning the 10 cents that we've got for
the current year looking forward, they
haven't recovered back this year versus
two years ago, back to 12 cents of
earnings.
So it could be the worst stock in the
sector.
You have to use common sense here.
Don't just blindly follow the process.
Think at every stage about what you're
looking at.
So for example, if we are eyeballing,
having attention to detail and some common
sense, when we're looking at our example
here on the screen, we would notice very
quickly if we looked at, for example, Levi
Strauss, that they have 433% earnings
growth for EG1.
And that is a move of EPS going from 21
cents to a dollar and 12 cents.
And we can also see a big number, for
example, for G3 apparel at 333% for EG1.
And that is EPS going from 55 cents to
$2.39.
So not only do we have a problem in our
example sector here, where we have for PVH
Corp and Under Armour going from losses to
profits, and we have to overwrite the
sales manually for 100%.
We also potentially have a problem here in
the sector when we're doing our
quantitative processing of the laws of
small numbers.
So percentage changes based on EPS coming
from a low number, a small number, and
moving to a higher number, creating very
high percentages that could ultimately
flatter the reality of those stocks.
And this could have an outsized impact on
our interpretation and meaning of what's
actually going on for these stocks and in
the sector.
Which brings us on to our next issue,
which is contributions to the mean, so
contributions to the sector averages.
So once you have actually cleansed your
data, and you're very confident that all
of the live cells and all of the numbers
have been attained as accurate, so the
stock price and EPS numbers, and all of
your formulas are correct.
Once you've actually cleansed your data,
you're going to then start to attempt at
making some sensible deductions about
forward-looking valuation in order to
identify positive and negative outliers
and everything in between.
And of course, what we want to be doing
here is identifying genuine positive and
negative outliers.
So in our example here, we've worked out
the mean values for earnings growth 1,
earnings growth 2, PE1, PE2, PEG1, PEG2,
the mean values for the sector.
And we've done that by dividing by the
amount of stocks in the sector.
So we're dividing by 9.
Now, when we look at the earnings growth
number for the apparel sector for EG1, we
have to ask ourselves a sensible question.
Is it sensible to assume that in the
apparel manufacturing sector that 117%
earnings growth is a real average for the
whole sector?
Well, common sense would tell us no.
When we look at the contributions of each
stock to the mean number, obviously, Levi
Strauss and G3 have an outsized
contribution relative to other stocks.
So the contribution from Levi and G3 is
large and it's skewing the mean and the
reality of the sector and it's creating a
scenario that is flattering the earnings
growth of the overall sector.
So why is this actually important?
Well, in your processing, you may actually
miss a positive outlier and potentially a
really great long idea because the
averages are just skewed.
And you may make the mistake of thinking
that Levi Strauss and G3, because they
just have much higher percentage earnings
growth versus the sector average, that
these are the positive outliers.
They may be.
They may not be.
But at this stage, we have to understand
that they're having an outsized
contribution to the mean relative to other
stocks in the sector.
And that could be flattering the overall
sector in terms of earnings growth and
leading us down the wrong path to make
incorrect deductions and interpretations
of what's going on with the sector and all
the stocks in the sector.
So what can we do about this?
Well, we can stress test the stocks and
have a look at calculating their
contributions to the mean and get a better
understanding of what happens when we
eliminate these stocks to the sector
itself and our own interpretation and
deductions of what's going on in the rest
of the sector.
Now, we can't do that without Levi Strauss
and G3 in the sector without Levi Strauss
and G3 in the sector.
So we can overwrite the cells and type a
zero in them.
And instead of dividing by nine, we can
just divide by seven to check their
contributions to the mean.
And here we discover that Levi Strauss and
G3 contribute around 75% to the 117%
earnings growth one number because when we
eliminate them, we are left with an
average of 41.38%.
And we can do something else as well.
If we repeat the exercise, but only with
Levi's eliminated and we divide by eight,
we get an earnings growth one number for
the mean of 78%.
Meaning Levi's contributes 39% to the 117%
sector average.
And G3 around 36% to the sector average.
So again, we have to use some common sense
here.
The earnings growth two number when we
look another year forward is 50%, which we
would probably consider a more normal, but
still high level of earnings growth for
this sector.
And we take note that the sector for the
previous financial year is coming out of
problems.
So it looks like the sector as a whole is
having some sort of turnaround and then
return to normalization.
So it looks like pretty much everything is
a turnaround play in this sector, except
for perhaps stocks like Contour and
Hannah's Brands.
So Contour has 40% earnings growth for EG1
and 11% for EG2.
And Hannah's Brands has 11% earnings
growth for EG1 and 7.5% for EG2.
And these numbers seem more like sensible
or normal earnings growth numbers for a
company that's in a sector like apparel
manufacturing.
Now you'll notice here that we've also
highlighted the Under Armour PE1 at 96.42
and the negative pegs of Capri Holdings
and VFC.
We'd also need to go through the same
exercise of working out all of their
contributions to the mean as well to get
some perspective on what's going on there
too.
You'll also notice that for the peg ones
for Levi Strauss and G3, we've also
overwritten the peg one cells.
We've done this because when we overwrote
the earnings growth numbers with zero, it
corrupted those cells.
Now, in this particular situation, when we
have a scenario like this in a sector like
this, we would look more towards year two
for clues on outliers.
And we would anchor ourselves to an
earnings growth rate of 40 to 50%.
And this is because when we overwrote
earnings growth one for Levi Strauss and
for G3 apparel, we were left with 41.38%
earnings growth for the sector average in
EG1.
And having made no changes in the column
for EG2, we have an earnings growth number
for the sector average, which is 50%.
So over the next couple of years, it seems
that 40 to 50% earnings growth is probably
going to be quite normal for this sector.
So what does that leave us with?
It leaves us with Capri Holdings with an
earnings growth two number of 144%, Under
Armour with an EG2 number of 79%, and VFC
with an EG2 number of 126%.
So these are starting to look like
interesting potential positive outliers.
Additionally, when we look at the PE2
column for the sector, we see that there's
a sector average of 21 and a half times
earnings.
And when we look at Under Armour and VFC,
we see that the PE2 for both of those
stocks is higher than the sector average.
And when we look at the PE2 for Capri
Holdings, we see that comes in lower than
the sector average.
When we're not adjusting the PE2 for Under
Armour, which has the highest PE2 in the
sector and is obviously making a very
large contribution to the overall sector
mean.
Now, bear in mind, we haven't even put a
market cap filter into our process here
yet.
So let's do that now as a useful exercise.
So we put a market cap filter on and we're
looking for potential long ideas here.
And given that VFC has a market cap of $33
billion, this only leaves Capri and Under
Armour as potential positive outliers in
the sector.
However, it is obvious that they are not
sequentially positive earnings growth
momentum stocks.
It's pretty obvious that they are still
turnarounds.
So if you were looking for long ideas in
this sector, at this moment in time, this
is how you would have gone through your
processing
to ensure that you're making no mistakes
and you're actually going through the
processing with the correct data and
asking obvious questions along the way and
making sensible, common sense
interpretations of the data.
And then, of course, if you think you've
identified what are potential positive
outliers or even negative outliers, you
would then go off and do the work to find
out what is behind the earnings growth
numbers.
What is behind the valuation?
What is driving the EPS?
What is driving the earnings growth?
What is driving the valuation premium or
discount?
Remember, there is always a reason why
something trades on a premium or a
discount.
So now we move from the identification
phase and we go on to the evidential, the
evidence
phase.
So as you can see, in order for us to make
sensible conclusions with meaning, when
we're
going through the quantitative process, we
can't make the mistakes.
We've got to get the data right.
We've got to get our spreadsheets clean
and correct and accurate.
And we have to have attention to detail in
order to do that.
And we have to have common sense to make
sensible interpretations.
Another mistake that we see is not so much
a processing data mistake, more of a
market
knowledge and common sense mistake or
misunderstanding.
So when analyzing a sector, we mentioned
earlier that it's important to get the
right
EPS numbers or the correct financial years
for each stock in the correct cells.
So everything lines up correctly.
And in our example, Capri Holdings and VFC
both had their financial year end on March
31st.
So what this means is, is that the year
two for these stocks is further out by one
quarter relative
to the other stocks in the sector, the
rest of the sector is going to report
their Q4 numbers and full year results in
either January or February 2022.
And Capri and VFC are going to report
their 2021 full year numbers in April or
May 2022.
So it's important to do this and
understand this because as we get further
and further through a financial year,
and the market gets more visibility on
revenue and earnings for that year and for
the company versus forward looking
estimates that are existing out there in
the market.
So the probability of a surprise that's
either negative or positive just simply
becomes less and less.
So for most sectors, and because most
stocks have a financial year that ends on
December 31st,
by Q4 of a company's financial year,
they've already reported three quarters of
revenue and earnings data
and all the balance sheet, profit and loss
and cash flow data for those three
quarters.
And we only have at this stage one quarter
left in the year.
So most companies report on the basis of a
financial year of Jan 1 to Dec 31.
So by October of any financial or calendar
year, as long as the sector isn't wildly
seasonal,
then the probability of having a surprise
to annual numbers that's coming only from
Q4,
so the probability of an overall surprise
that a company can miss or beat earnings
or revenue data,
the probability is lower than, for
example, earlier in the year or even the
beginning of the year.
Because now there's much more visibility
on the current year.
So a company's own forecasts and forecasts
from research analysts in most sectors
tend to begin focusing on next year's
estimates, next year's numbers,
as soon as we enter Q4 and the Q3 earnings
day is officially behind us.
Now, in our example, it just so happens
with the apparel sector that they get most
of their revenue
and earnings in the Q4 holiday season.
So again, we have to think about the
sector that we're looking at, the stocks
that we're looking at,
and how they report.
What is their financial year?
Are they seasonal?
What is the probability of surprise?
What time of the year are we in right now?
We have to use a lot of common sense to
understand what's going on.
So most of the time, when we enter a
calendar Q4, because most stocks have a
financial year end
of December 31st, their financial year is
a calendar year.
When we enter Q4, it's all about next
year.
It's not about this year for most stocks,
especially if the stocks are not very
seasonal
to the holiday season.
So we have to use common sense and we have
to look forwards.
We have to look out to the following year.
So again, this is not so much a data
processing issue.
There are data processing elements in
there, but it's more of a common sense
issue.
Now, as mentioned earlier, as we move from
the identification phase,
and we've got all of our data right, we've
cleaned our data,
we've got all of our formulas right, we've
made good common sense interpretations of
the data.
We're going to move from the discovery or
identification phase
into the evidence phase.
And this is where we might start adding in
extra quant.
So we might start adding in, for example,
revenues and revenue growth
and backwards looking quant.
And at this stage, we've seen many
mistakes from retail traders here as well.
The most common mistake is to do this step
before getting to the sector stage
and trying to do it for hundreds of stocks
or all 2200 plus stocks in the
spreadsheet.
Next up, the most common mistake is doing
it before actually cleansing the forward
looking estimates
and valuation data. So not going through
the discovery phase first, not going
through
the identification phase first. Do not do
this.
Even after that stage, there are mistakes.
Trying to do it for every stock in the
sector.
Remember, always, you should be seeking to
work smart and efficiently.
For longs and shorts, we have market cap
filters.
So you can get to answers quickly by
eliminating a lot of stocks.
And once you've done this, you can start
to explore the backwards looking quant in
a separate Excel sheet.
Keep it simple, stupid.
Don't become an analyst with massive
spreadsheets and end up going down major
rabbit holes.
The law of diminishing marginal utility
applies here.
You can find the positive and negative
outliers and everything else in between by
cleansing the data
and drawing on common sense.
The rest is now evidence or exploratory
work.
Another issue we see with retail traders
going through these processes
is the problem of trying to compare apples
to pez.
What we're trying to do here all the time
is reflect reality and compare apples to
apples.
So after cleansing data and feeling very
confident that your sector reflects
reality
as closely as possible, there needs to be
some discretionary fine tuning in the next
stage.
At this stage, what you've actually done
is you've created your own sector to
reflect reality.
And this is an exercise that 99% of market
participants will never engage in.
And what you need to be very careful of at
this stage is to engage in the exercise
of comparing apples to pez instead of
comparing apples to apples.
So we are seeking to reflect the reality
of a sector.
So we are seeking to assess market
valuation and growth rates of comparable
businesses
or comparable stocks in order to assess
what the market likes and what the market
dislikes.
So we can identify positive and negative
outliers and everything else in between.
So we can't, for example, compare growth
rates like earnings growth or revenue
growth rates,
for example, of say $200 billion companies
to the growth rates of $1 billion
companies.
You have to also check the contributions
to the means of the largest market cap
companies
and the small cap and mid cap
contributions to the mean.
If a sector exhibits wildly different
growth rates and valuations of mega and
large cap versus mid and small caps,
you can split the sector using a market
cap filter and then compare the two
sectors that you've split out
based on market cap alongside each other.
And you can cut and paste your findings to
another sheet and just look at mega and
large cap
versus small and mid cap growth rates and
valuations.
In addition to that, you now have to
compare similar businesses.
You're going to find that there will be
many occasions when you drill down to a
subsector.
There will be stocks in there that seem to
have no place in the sector at all
because they are in a different business
area to the rest of the stocks in the
sector.
So remember our classification systems
here.
These are NAICS and GICS classifications.
They are not your classifications.
And you have to fix it and create your own
sector that reflects reality and compares
apples to apples, not apples to pears.
So let's summarize here, guys.
In the quantitative process, the
identification process within trade idea
generation,
the identification process within the
sector that you have to look at in the
sector.
Use common sense and have attention to
detail.
Do not download spreadsheets from
third-party sources and believe all the
data is accurate.
And do not just look at sector data and
get lazy
by looking for high PE and low PE stocks
or even high earnings growth and low
earnings growth.
And then you think it's an idea.
You have to eyeball the data.
You have to clean the data, cleanse the
data and build your own sectors to reflect
reality as closely as possible.
As mentioned earlier, what you've seen
here, 99% of market participants will
never ever do this work.
They don't have a systematic process or
trade idea generation like you do.
They don't even have that and they won't
even do any work on data.
This is where you can get a significant
edge in the market.
It's a proprietary process.
And if you have attention to detail with a
strong interpretation of your findings,
so an interpretation that requires common
sense, that's going to lead to very
accurate and exciting conclusions.
So make sure you have attention to detail.
You work on your common sense and your
interpretation.
It will get better over time.
And don't be afraid to do the work.
Practice, practice, practice.
Okay, guys.
So this brings us to the end of this
video.
Data mining and processing mistakes with
the solutions.
Next up, we're going to recap the
quantitative process.